one of the most disgusting Republican members
of the House right now is Steve King. I'm
not going to [inaudible], I'm gonna
go through his full repulsive credentials
for you, but they include everything from
coddling and excusing, white nationalism,
extreme religious hysteria. Even many Republican
organizations have condemned Steve King as
the disgusting racist that he is. Steve King
one spoke about being upset that white nationalist
is now considered offensive. He once told
Breitbart news that he doesn't want Muslims
working in meat packing plants because quote,
I don't want people doing my pork that won't
eat it, let alone hope I go to hell for eating
pork chops. He equated the torture and a prisoner
abuse of the AGU Ghraib prison to quote hazing.
And he subscribes to this white genocide conspiracy
theory known as the great replacement, which
we've talked about a few times now, but I
won't go into detail about now. So anyway,
needless to say, this is a horrible, horrible
person. He now is saying that we should credit
rape and incest for the existence of humanity.
That in a sense, if it were not for rape and
incest because it apparently is very common,
his mind, um, it is, it would be destructive
to humanity and therefore maybe rape and incest
aren't that bad. And thus there should be
no such exceptions for rape and incest. When
you talk about abortion law, when I saw the
headline, part of me didn't want to believe
it. Even if it was Steve King. Even for Steve
King, it sounded a little bit too much. I
don't want to speak for Steve King. So here
he is. Yesterday in Urbandale, Iowa. This
is out of his own mouth.
What if it was okay and what if we went back
through all the family trees and just pulled
those people out that were products of rape
and incest? Would there be any population
of the world left if we did that? Considering
all the wars and all the rape and fillers
has taken place and then whatever happened,
they told her after society, I know I can't
certify that they're not not part of a product
of that. So
I guess the argument is we should not have
a rape and incest exceptions for abortion
bans because if we did, humanity wouldn't
exist because rape and incest have been so
prominent in the perpetuation of Homo sapiens
around the world is Steve King feeling like
with Donald Trump in the White House, he's
no longer getting attention for saying really
dumb things. Like is he, uh, realizing that
there's someone actually more repugnant and
reprehensible who's getting a lot of attention
for the things he says and he wants some of
that attention back to Trump. I read a funny
comment. Something like Steve King is from
Iowa. He mostly knows people who are the products
of rape and incest. And that's why he thinks
that without rape and incest, there'd be no
humanity. I read that on the Internet, but
that would be a distasteful joke to make.
So I'm not going to make it today.
Uh, Steve King also suggested during the same
speech in Urbandale, Iowa that there's a plot
to remove him from power. And I want to talk
about that because the way Steve King presents
it, there's some kind of conspiracy or subterfuge
to remove him from his seat. In the House
of Representatives, I call it something else,
I call it. He has an opponent and there is
actually really good news. The opponent is
our friend j d Scholten who is running again
against Steve King. You can support j d you
can maybe vote for JD if you live in Iowa's
fourth district. So we met j d Scholten back
in 2018 August of 2018 I went to net roots
nation in New Orleans, Louisiana, interviewed
a few different 2018 candidates. One of them
was j d Scholten. J D Scholten is a actually
a political outsider with really good ideas.
He's a progressive. He recognizes the horrible
nature of Steve King.
I tweeted with him a few weeks ago and said,
hey, are you running again in 2020 because
it would really be great to remove Steve King
and he said at the time he wasn't sure. He
has since announced that he is running again.
So we're going to try to get JD Scholten on
the show and talk to him. He lost by only
10,000 votes to Steve King in 2018. This is
a significantly red leaning district. Iowa's
fourth district and j d Scholten came within
10,000 votes. Just three percentage points
separating them. Steve Scholten, uh, Steve
King could lose to j d Scholten in 2020. I
hope you'll check out JD Shelton's campaign,
uh, contribute if that's the way you want
to activate work to get out the vote, vote
in that election if you live in Iowa's fourth
district. But we'll definitely be talking
about that one more. As much as we would've
loved to see Ted Cruz be removed by better
or worse in 2018, I would love to see JD Scholten
removed disgusting bottom theater, Steve King
in 2020 and we're going to do what we can
to make that happen.